le canard laqué de pékin là vous pourrez
pas m'avoir en une phrase l'ap renom le
bleu sénateurs représentant les français
établis hors de france et secrétaire
général adjoint les républicains en
charge des relations avec les mouvements
politiques étrangers
alors plutôt le meilleur pâtissier
trois dynamiques le foot à les kanji
[Musique]
dans l'astrologie sûrement pas non à
bout toujours la francité ions mais
plutôt l'om en fait oui haribo et
rimbaud ligue de champions les deux
robes erasmus les deux quand on est
français de l'étranger
le patron coup
[Musique]
on va écouter lasser les deux thomas
pesquet formidable flexitariens
[Musique]
qu'on en sorte un jour et on se fassent
vacciner qu'on en soit jean reno j'adore
[Musique]
la version française oss 117
ah le canard laqué de pékin skyrock pour
la musique
france inter oc al sans parachute d'une
fois mais je crois que c'était la
dernière
[Musique]